houston is my hometown it's a special
place in my heart i feel terrible
whatever we could do i want to help i
want to support all ways that's my duty
that's what i got to do and we're just
sending prayers and we send in
condolences and we send in positive
energy to everybody in that family megan
the stallion sharing her reaction to the
tragedy at the astroworld festival her
is following a number of other tributes
from the music industry
[Applause]
performed at astroworld hours before the
deadly crowd crush she later took to
twitter writing speechless about last
night i'm actually in shock and don't
even know what to say marin morris
tweeted no one should fear going to a
show and not coming back safely while
kid cudi shared my heart goes out to the
families who lost a loved one last night
and everyone who was injured i just want
to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost last night
we've been working closely
we've been working closely with everyone
to just try to get to the bottom list
travis scott got emotional in this video
shared to his instagram story our fans
really mean the world to me on monday it
was reported that travis is providing
refunds to all astro world attendees the
rapper and live nation entertainment
astroworld's concert promoter are now
facing several lawsuits
if you have any information
um
you know please just contact your local
authorities
um
everybody continue to just keep your
prayers i mean i'm
i'm honestly just devastated and
i could never imagine anything like this
just
happening
i'm gonna do everything i can to keep
you guys updated and
just keep you guys
informed on what's going on
love you all